President Trump has faced strong
bipartisan criticism for the way he
responded to the deadly white
supremacist protests in Charlottesville
throughout history American presidents
have condemned racially motivated
attacks and addressed racial tension
from John F Kennedy to George HW Bush
and Ronald Reagan presidents have
reminded the country over and over again
that racism bigotry and hate will not be
tolerated this nation was founded by men
of many nations and backgrounds it was
founded on the principle that all men
are created equal and that the rights of
every man are diminished when the rights
of one man are threatened I urge every
member of both parties Americans of all
religions and of all colors from every
section of this country to join me in
that cause I would like to address a few
remarks to those groups who still adhere
to senseless racism and religious
prejudice I would say to them you are
the ones who are out of step with our
society you are the ones who willfully
violate the meaning of the dream that is
America and this country because if such
what it stands for will not stand for
your conduct these people are working to
create a climate of understanding and
tolerance a climate that refuses to
accept racism bigotry anti-semitism and
hate of any kind anytime anywhere
removing the flag from this States
Capitol would not be an act of political
correctness it would not be an insult to
the Valor of Confederate soldiers it
would simply be an acknowledgment
but the cause for which they fought the
cause of slavery was wrong that was from
President Obama speaking after the
massacre at Emanuel AME Church in
Charleston
but Charlie could we just stop for a
second because it's very powerful to see
the presidents from all the different
parties and I think president Trump
would say I've said those two but when
you say those words followed by but it
sort of negates everything that you said
and we're back the next day that's right
say I really meant what I said
differences they say it leave it it's
not but blah blah blah blah blah
very powerful